pues finalmente se produjo esta renuncia
a pesar que de que no él lo encajete
estaba muy reticente a hacerlo pero
fueron sobre todo las personas más
allegadas a él las que lograron
convencerlo y pues esta mañana en este
comité ejecutivo que todavía está
reunido aquí en la sede de la federación
se dio a conocer Ya esta decisión sobre
todo pues esto venía una tormenta
mediática sobre Noel desde comienzos de
este año por eh declaraciones que él
había hecho en contra jugador Intocable
aquí en el país pero sobre todo por esa
auditoría que pidió el Ministerio de
deportes y que reveló Pues un uso
manejos muy centralizados por parte de
un consumo excesivo de alcohol y sobre
todo una persona pues que ya no contaba
con ese deber de ejemplaridad que tiene
quien debe representar al fútbol francés
en el mundo todo esto además de todas
estas revelaciones acusaciones de acoso
sexual y moral que ahora están siendo
también pues investigadas por la
fiscalía en Francia en todo caso en el
comunicado sí se deja por sentado que de
todas maneras la gestión a lo largo de
estos once años a cargo de la federación
ha sido buenos en cuanto a éxitos tanto
deportivos como económicos